all right let's talk a little bit about
politics before we wrap up because
there's always somebody that wants to
you know bang on about politics and get
an opinion so what did this guy hear say
i agree with a lot of your content but
it seems to me that you're just kind of
mad that joe biden won
i don't know where you stand politically
with both sides but judging from
your tweets i don't know i i don't care
to be honest with you
um i think this i think it's
entertaining
from my perspective that your entire
nation when i say here i'm talking about
americans voted for a guy like it's like
voting for a guy and i tweeted about
this
voting for biden is like knowing you've
got a four-year road trip that you got
to take
and you have a selection of a bunch of
different vehicles
and you pick the one with you know uh
ball tires
uh 500 000 miles on it it's it's it's
barely holding on it's got a burnt out
headlight
a couple of busted tail lights and the
brakes barely work but you want to take
that for the four year road trip
that's literally what americans decided
to do
and in fact it's also kind of funny from
another perspective that there's dead
people voting
for biden against trump people hate
trump so much
that they came back from the dead and
voted against him
i find all of this interesting and
fascinating as hell i don't know about
you guys so
here's the thing about politics guys
here's the thing about politics
all right nobody cares it does not
matter
if it's republican democrat in canada
we've got
many more parties we've got uh the
conservative party the liberal party the
new democrat party the
people's party of canada which is a
libertarian party
we've got all these parties here you
guys have two main parties
but everybody's fighting amongst
themselves over who's got
the bigger d it's a big d swinging
contest
is what i see here and neither one of
the two
is going to make any difference in the
world at the end of the day in your
personal world at the end of the day
so my political views are um you know
i'll i'll restate two different
positions
um because when did my grandfather die
it was 80
88 or nine or so anyway he died a long
time ago but
he was about 86 at the time and i
remember him saying when
i was real young we were talking about
politics um
and he was not a entrepreneur he was not
a capitalist he was a
military guy worked for the royal air
force did a lot of um
you know hands-on jobs uh he was uh
uh what the hell were they kyle um
flying boats
uh sunderlands i think they were called
the was it to haveland sunderland
anyway the boat was a uh there's a
flying boat called
sunderland he did a lot of work around
that for many many years um
he was a a grunt okay he was basically a
aircraft mechanic uh and he always said
if you've got the choice between the two
between liberals and conservatives
the conservatives are the ones that are
least like least likely to eff
up the economy okay so if you have to
narrow down between the two
i'm with grandad on that and um that's
what i would rely on
and it's not because i hate biden or
because i like trump or any of those
things and
those opinions really don't matter
there's some very very strange people
out there that take this [ __ ] very very
seriously
they've been sleeping in their maga hats
for the last five years and there's
people that have been
you know on the other side manufacturing
stories and
impeachments and collusions and all this
stuff has been made up over the last
four
you know four years it seems you know to
discredit uh trump
and then on the other side of the coin
there's all these other things you know
they're going on with somebody like
kamala for example
who nobody's saying anything about today
that she slept her way to the top or
or had some help along the way let's
just water down a little bit she she
definitely had
a significant amount of help along the
way what i believe though at the end of
the day guys
is is in sovereignty it's a you know
it's about control
and freedom and just keeping the
government and the state out of my life
okay it doesn't matter which political
party you choose they're always going to
be involved in your life
uh i don't see anybody any of these
political parties saying
you know what family law is screwed we
need to revamp family law
and level the playing field and not make
it so hostile towards men i haven't seen
either political party say that right
i haven't seen anybody talk about
anything
that matters for the betterment of
society it's always about
bigger government more control more
um influence and impact on our
individual lives and less personal
freedoms
is one party better than the other i'm
with granddad conservative right
but at the end of the day i'm more of a
libertarian when i vote here in canada i
vote for libertarian policies
um low taxes personal freedoms that's
what i'm after but unfortunately
nobody um like the
candidate here in canada uh what's his
name maxime
bernier or max bernier i think i i don't
even think they got one seat
in parliament not even one everybody
voted for conservative
liberal or new democrat party here and
it seems like it's the same thing in the
state you know you guys are divided on
democrat republican at the end of the
day it's the same crap
i put on instagram the other day it's
like choosing between
you know do you want to be constipated
or to have diarrhea it's all the same
[ __ ] it's just different whatever you
know um
let me grab this super chat here real
quick from ryan ryan says
uh do you think the tensions with china
iran might be going to war with biden
as president look
i don't follow the news the news has
no impact on my day-to-day life and i
encourage you guys to cancel cable
not follow the news it doesn't matter it
it's it's
you know if you think that your views
you know your opinion arguing about it
on on facebook getting into battles with
you know the cairns of the world
unfriending people blocking people it's
like i've never seen
society this divided in my entire life
over something that's
as silly as politics you know and
it's it's again it's the same [ __ ] just
different texture
right it's all about big government
bigger government over
time more control and less personal
freedoms
and if you want my opinion guys you
should be voting for less of that
smaller government more personal
freedoms more sovereignty
that's my view um joe uses camilla as a
trophy somebody said here
and of course we've got losers like this
oh boy everybody's everybody's so
divided
over politics you know you're either
you know a biden guy or your trump guy
it's like
you know what stop having your identity
attached
to an old man that's about to kick the
bucket
just because he opposes the other
candidate because you think
he's this that or the other thing you
know
a lot of people waste far too much time
and energy
in politics in my view and i really
really think that
there's a lot better things you can do
with your time
than watching everything that goes down
on your favorite news media station
they're all they're all skewed in one
direction or the other if you watch
fox news you're gonna get a different
story from cnn
right you watch cnbc it'll be different
from the other guy
it really it it really depends on what
it is you want to do with your time and
if you want to hang around
you know arguing with with people about
politics and who's got the the better
leader
i can tell you this my life isn't going
to change and the lives of many of you
guys aren't going to change whether
biden or trump is leading the country
for the next four years
it's not going to be that much different
again it's like choosing between
hard-ass constipation and runny diarrhea
it's all [ __ ]
at the end of the day anyway that's my
take on it guys
um don't uh don't spend too too much
time
um you know burning through politics and
the news and fighting with people and
creating enemies and
friends based on political divisions
it's it's it's just ridiculous i mean
there are some out to lunch people out
there on both sides of the camp i'll be
honest with you like i said there's some
there's some whack jobs that have been
sleeping in their maga hats for four
years straight
and there's also some whack jobs that
constantly bang on and
make up stuff about um donald trump is
the president you know for the last
years
just get off your high horses dude get
off your soapboxes and
work on your inner self that's what you
can control control the man
this is the mental point of origin story
right that rollo created this
this this is what really matters to men
into masculinity
at the end of the day
you